has there ever been a time when someone
wasn't kind to you as
when you were a guest star and you felt
like they were just a little um
condescending or like oh you're the
pretty guest star [ __ ] you
yeah yeah you definitely have felt that
and it wasn't just you feeling that
or thinking like it was you felt that
was what i'm saying
yeah and it wasn't exactly that way it
was a show
where the lead i don't think wanted me
there
so we did all of her coverage and then
when they turned around on me she told
me her stand-in was gonna do her lines
she was gonna go home so it was
it wasn't like it was like a respect
thing it was like uh i'm not gonna say i
know you're not gonna say
it was worth a shot yeah jeez can you
imagine but i've had other bad you know
i i did it
i did an hbo show that i left
i didn't go back and they apologized for
what had happened
what happened a little me too stuff
really
and i yeah i didn't return and and and i
was like oh god they're never gonna hbo
is never going to work with me again and
it was just that particular did you
did you say it did you mince it on
social media mention it no
it wasn't it wasn't like a direct direct
thing it was it was
anyway something made you uncomfortable
yes very uncomfortable and you said i'm
not coming back
i don't feel safe i wish i i went to my
hotel room that night and
called my agent and i was shaking um
but again it wasn't a direct thing it
was the environment
of the show and what they were doing
especially
with like sudden rewrites where you're
doing something that
wasn't scripted was not appropriate
right um
but it wasn't hbo it was that
environment
whomever was running the show was
allowing that right